ladies and gentlemen uh we're of course
at the height of the holiday season
right now and as usual
the television networks are inundating
us with holiday specials
it seems anyone who wants their own
special can have one
and nowhere was that more apparent than
last week
when martha stewart had her christmas
special
and hosted it with one of late night's
most beloved characters
if you missed it it was quite strange
check out a few of these highlights
[Music]
tchaikovsky's renowned christmas ballet
the nutcracker suite
the dance of the sugarplum fairy has
always been one of my
favorite moments as a girl i would sit
forward in my seat
waiting for the prima ballerina to enter
on her toes
pirouetting through a glittering world
of holiday confections
and spectacular sweets what really
attracted my attention though
was the fairy's magic wand
sorry genie not a snow cloud in that sky
but i'm still hoping for a white
christmas i bet you'd like to play with
all those other animals in the snow
i
[Music]
i'm going to would these wonderful
cutout cookies these are sugar cookies
with a simple two-step technique called
flooding and flocking
outline the cookie very neatly
and flood the whole center
[Music]
that's not right that's not right
it chromos tom all right uh taylor break
when we come back dweezil and ahmet
zappa will be here
you